[Música]
tras seis votaciones en dos jornadas la
cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos no ha elegido portavoz el ala
dura de los republicanos sigue
bloqueando la elección del nominado del
partido que vive mccarthy la tensa
situación incluso llevó al presidente
Donald Trump a pedir unidad
el gobierno de Colombia suspendido los
efectos del decreto de cese el juego
bilateral con la guerrilla del ejército
de liberación nacional eln esto luego de
que esa organización delincuencial
afirmara que no hay ningún acuerdo al
respecto
nueva jornada de paro nacional en Perú
al menos 35 puntos en vías nacionales
fueron bloqueados en medio de las
protestas contra el gobierno y la
represión durante las manifestaciones de
diciembre ampliamos desde Lima
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Estados Unidos donde la atención
política aumenta pues la cámara de
representantes de mayoría republicana no
ha conseguido ponerse de acuerdo para
elegir a un nuevo presidente tras seis
votaciones la elección de Kevin mccarthy
el nominado republicano ha sido
bloqueada por un grupo de
ultraderechistas de su partido que se
opone a su gestión lo que llevó al
expresidente Donald Trump y al
presidente Joe biden a pedir a los
legisladores que se pongan de acuerdo
Andrés granadillo nos cuenta quién es el
aspirante el tercer cargo más importante
del país Kevin mccarthy es un hombre de
57 años que vive en un Distrito
conservador en el estado demócrata por
excelencia California desde que llegó a
Washington en 2007 quiere presidir la
cámara representantes en 2015 casi gana
la Silla cuando el republicano John
berner anunció su renuncia pero los
choques con los representantes del
freedom Cocos el ala más conservadora de
los republicanos se lo impidieron los
mismos que ahora se han opuesto a que
sea elegido cuando la entonces
presidenta de la cámara Nancy pelosi
inició uno de los juicios políticos
contra Donald Trump mccarthy fue uno de
los que se opuso
la presidenta es la presidenta de esta
cámara pero no habla por Estados Unidos
cuando se trata de este tema no puede
decidir unilateralmente lo que sucede
aquí han estado investigando a este
presidente incluso antes de que fuera
electo han votado tres veces sobre
juicio político Aquí
también hizo eco de las acusaciones
infundadas de fraude de Trump al perder
la presidencia y llamó a un recuento de
los votos
cada recuento debe terminarse tenemos
desafíos dentro de los tribunales cada
demanda debe ser escuchada
independientemente de a quien apoye en
esta elección al final del día queremos
que Estados Unidos esté Unido
Aunque republicano condenó el asalto al
Capitolio y denunció el comportamiento
de Donald Trump semanas después fue amar
al agua retractarse y a intentar
recuperar el aprecio del hombre que una
vez le llamó mi Kevin el portavoz de la
cámara de representantes es la tercera
persona con más poder en Estados Unidos
tras el presidente Joe biden y la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris seguimos
hablando de Estados Unidos porque
Washington reinició los servicios
consulares en su sede diplomática de la
Habana el gobierno cubano aplaudió la
medida Aunque criticó que no incluya el
otorgamiento de visas para los no
migrantes Rafael Pérez con los detalles
un nuevo paso en las relaciones entre
Cuba y Estados Unidos washington reabrió
Las puertas de su embajada para los
servicios consulares tras años de pausa
los cubanos expresaron su satisfacción
para realizar cualquier trámite
migratorio rumbo Norte tenían que viajar
hacia otro país muchos cubanos se
desesperan y se van embalse y eso eso
eso yo no lo hago lo importante de la
embajada aquí es eso hice legal y sin
problema el cierre parcial de la
representación diplomática
estadounidense se dio en el año 2017 dos
años después del restablecimiento de las
relaciones con la Habana durante el
gobierno de Barack Obama la
administración Trump clausuró la sede
luego de que varios miembros del
personal diplomático estadounidense
presentarán dolencias principalmente
neurológicas tanto en la Habana como en
otras ciudades del mundo sin embargo fue
bautizado como el síndrome de La Habana
y según hipótesis se trata de ataques
sónicos la van a reaccionó a la nueva
apertura de la mano de su canciller
Aunque criticó que la medida no aplica
para los no inmigrantes reanudación del
proceso de visas para migrantes cubanos
desde embajada en la Habana es un paso
necesario y correcto aún no incluye
visas de no inmigrante lo que
obstaculiza visitas familiares e
intercambios culturales deportivos y
científicos para los que Cuba sigue
abierta la crisis económica en Cuba
grabada por la pandemia y los efectos
del embargo económico que la Casa Blanca
impone sobre la isla han hecho que cerca
de 250.000 cubanos hayan abandonado el
país de manera ilegal hacia la Unión
Americana tan solo en 2022 este hecho se
dan un complejo contexto migratorio para
Washington que intenta frenar uno de los
mayores flujos de migrantes de los
últimos años en su frontera Sur
vamos a Colombia porque el gobierno de
Gustavo Petro suspendió el decreto de cs
el fuego bilateral con la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional al
tiempo que le pidió al grupo
delincuencial que declare una tregua el
anuncio se produjo Solo un día después
de que el eln negara a ser parte del
acuerdo de cese el fuego por seis meses
anunciado por el jefe de estado del 31
de diciembre al que sí se sumaron otros
cinco grupos al margen de la ley el
ministro del interior de Colombia
Alfonso Prada aseguró que el tema será
tratado nuevamente durante la segunda
etapa de negociaciones que tendrá lugar
en México ante la posición asumida
públicamente el día de ayer según la
cual debería llevar a la mesa de diálogo
el protocolo de dicho cese hemos
decidido suspender los efectos jurídicos
del decreto 2657 del 31 de diciembre del
2022 en Perú se llevó a cabo una nueva
jornada de paro nacional en la que al
menos 35 puntos de vías del país fueron
bloqueados los ciudadanos protestan
contra el gobierno de Dina boluarte
piden la dimisión de la mandataria al
tiempo que ponen al proceso contra el
destituido presidente Pedro Castillo a
esta jornada se suma la condena a la
represión de las manifestaciones de
diciembre en las que alrededor de 30
personas perdieron la vida desde Lima
Francisco Zacarías nos dio más detalles
del paro
la protestas en Perú contra el gobierno
de la presidenta Dina boluarte bloquean
siete vías nacionales y 35 puntos de
tránsito en seis regiones del país según
la superintendencia de transportes lo
manifestantes exigen la renuncia de la
mandataria peruana el cierre del
Congreso la convocatoria elecciones
generales y a una asamblea Constituyente
la presidenta boluarte formuló un
llamado a la paz y a la unidad y el
diálogo y ratificó la voluntad de su
gobierno para atender las necesidades de
la población por su parte el Primer
Ministro Alberto tárula pidió a los
manifestantes a que respeten la vida e
integridad de las personas tras la
reactivación de las protestas Mientras
tanto la defensoría del pueblo reporta
manifestaciones en 30 provincias del
Perú que se despliegan entre marchas y
bloqueo de vías se han registrado de
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y la
policía en algunas localidades del sur
de Perú el organismo no ha reportado
ningún fallecido ni herido durante la
jornada de lucha Lima también fue
escenario de movilizaciones en el centro
de la ciudad fue dispersada con gases
lacrimógenos lanzados por la policía
contra manifestantes que bloqueaban
algunas avenidas las protestas van a
continuar este jueves con movilizaciones
y paros convocados al interior al Perú
en las localidades de Arequipa cajamarca
chinchero y lo Mariscal nieto y huánuco
el desborde social en este país se
inició en diciembre pasado luego que el
congreso destituyó a Pedro Castillo por
intentar disolver el parlamento
intervenir la justicia y Establecer un
régimen de excepción en México
científico se ambientalistas alertan
sobre los costos ambientales de la
construcción del tren Maya que aseguran
afectaría múltiples especies de la
región y abastecimientos de agua potable
un proyecto del presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador que tendría un costo de 20
mil millones de dólares y generaría
miles de empleos el informes de Manuela
Cano
la construcción del tren Maya Abre cada
vez más polémicas se trata de uno de los
proyectos del presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador que busca promover
el turismo en la Península de Yucatán en
el sureste del país lo que se va a
buscar Precisamente es que la gente que
llega a Cancún 30 millones de visitantes
en vez de que se queden nada más en
Cancún o que lleguen hasta Playa del
Carmen puedan
internarse en todo Quintana Roo el
ambicioso proyecto que costará unos 20
mil millones de dólares enciende las
alarmas de múltiples organizaciones
ambientalistas su construcción aseguran
dividir a parte de la selva mexicana
generando un enorme perjuicio para las
especies que viven en dichos ecosistemas
como los jaguares A causar un efecto
Barrera que interrumpe la conectividad o
el corredor biológico por donde se
desplazan estas especies Así que muy
importante mantener esos corredores
biológicos que queremos tener a la
especie en un futuro aquí en nuestro
país
el gobierno mexicano Espera que la
construcción finalice Este 2023 pero
expertos alertan que los efectos ya se
están sintiendo sobre todo en las cuevas
subterráneas típicas de la región que
retienen agua potable y ahora lo que
estamos registrando en este día que ya
hace unas semanas se metieron unos
barrenos de exploración y donde arriba
ya están metiendo pilotes para sostener
el tren acá lo que estamos viendo Es que
ya hay este material de construcción que
no pertenece a la cueva los riesgos
ambientales contrastan con las cifras
que según fonatur la agencia encargada
del proyecto generará el tren según sus
cálculos para 2030 podría sacar a más de
un millón de personas de la pobreza y
crear hasta 715.000 nuevos empleos fin
del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]